but I want to tell you guys a little bit
related to the book is that it's really
been an adventure so I'm guessing that
most of you haven't written a book and
this is my first one and as some of you
know for the last couple years I've been
trying to write a book and I would start
and stop and I could never sort of I
could tell some stories but it was I was
having trouble sort of getting it to a
point where it was saying something that
was that was truly authentic meaningful
that would be worthy of you spending
your money on and then in the last year
between touring with Jordan and doing
the show and some of the the mob stuff
going after me in front page of the New
York Times and that ridiculous all right
article and and so many things and just
watching all of the things that I've
been talking about on this show for
years they were sort of Fringe ideas
three years ago right when I was talking
about like what was happening with the
left and the false cries of racism and
bigotry and all of those things as ways
of winning arguments instead of actually
winning arguments with facts when I was
talking about that years ago it was just
starting to bubble up and I think that
that's probably what put me on a lot of
your radars so if you guys are liberals
or let's say you were lefties or maybe
you're sort of begrudging lis lefties
now it's like I was starting to say
something that now everyone sees is very
obvious like what's happening with the
progressives right now they've really
gone off the rails and they're just
dragging the Democrats with them where
where are the good Democrats where are
the classical liberals where are the
old-school Blue Dog Democrats we're in
the JFK's I don't know I talked about
that in this book and I come up with
some prescriptions at the end and if
you're a conservative I think what
brought you here probably was that you
never saw someone that was kind of
decent and had some liberal beliefs that
treated you like a human and didn't
think you were a racist bigoted
homophobe and just by sharing my
feelings about this and then and then
talking to people not every week but
often about that sort of set of issues
this is all to the backdrop of the rise
of Trump and everything else and then
how this culture war has just burst
forth into everything right now it's
it's in our political system it's in our
it's on our education system all of
these things around
like everything that we've talked about
here just kept sort of happening you
know we Brett Weinstein it at Evergreen
State being booted off campus basically
for fighting racism Lindsey Shepard at
Wilfrid Laurier basically being you know
reprimanded because she showed a Jordan
Peterson video in class a guy like James
d'amour who fought the diversity memo at
Google like all of these people kept
walking through this room and then there
was sort of the rise of the of the
intellectual dark web and the whole crew
whether it's whether it's Peterson and
say Ben Shapiro and me probably leaning
a little more right at this point or at
least let's say a little more Liberty
minded and then there's the guys that I
think still consider themselves left
need say the Weinstein brothers and Sam
Harris then a whole crew of people
that's something that we did in this
room which is in my garage I mean I'm in
my garage right now started becoming
really really culturally relevant and
then and then you know the the endless
haters and all of that nonsense and the
and the hit pieces from from Vox and
from HuffPo and the rest of it and you
know trying to get Peabody I was trying
to get mayor Pete on the show some of
you remember this about a month and a
half ago
and tweeted at his comms guy and the guy
said DM me and then suddenly HuffPo
journalists and Vox journalists and a
guy from Media Matters all jumped in you
know called me all sorts of bad names
and we had already gone back and forth
with boo to judge his team via email
about getting him on the show and then
they backed out of that and it's just
like this this war that's happening
about who you can talk to and when you
can talk to them so that that is what
this book is about learning learning to
fight the mob free thinking in an age of
unreason that's the subtitle because we
right now live in a time of unreason
everyone is sort of hysterical all the
time and all of those things